in the Turkish border town of suraj a
public outpouring of grief the women
mourned the death of their village chief
he and two other men were killed in a
mortar shelling an apparent reprisal
attack from across the border in Syria
[Music]
commitment is we want this war to stop
nobody should die no soldiers no
civilians we just want peace of thought
yet of course we're scared we are scared
for the whole country for Turks for
Kurds for everyone no one should be
killed
never seek you people show us where the
victims died within a radius of 20
meters traces of bomb fragments 2,000
O's walls vehicles battered by shrapnel
I don't think it came from that side
maybe from over there I don't know but
this is from a bomb similar stories can
be heard in many Turkish border towns if
people believe the war's just across the
border in Syria they know better now
still the mayor of action color supports
the Turkish offensive he claims the army
is fighting for a good cause
here in dr. Carla we are hosting 125,000
Syrians you might be able to imagine how
difficult that is we want a safe zone to
resettle the 3.5 million refugees that
have become a burden for Turkey over the
past eight and a half years Europe
occasionally sends a little money but we
pay the real price Syrians should go
back to their homes the area northeast
Syria that is supposed to become a safe
zone is anything but for days the
Turkish army and allied Syrian
opposition fighters have clashed with
Kurdish militia and while they are busy
fighting each other there are concerns
that Isis jihadists which were already
defeated in the area might be able to
regroup international criticism of the
Turkish military campaign is growing the
United Nations say the offensive has
caused more than 100,000 civilians to
flee but the consequences have also been
dramatic on this side of the border in
Turkey and many people we've talked to
here are hoping that the violence won't
continue to escalate this includes
people in search who are grieving over
the death of their village chief and
pray that the Turkish military operation
will end before they have to bury more
of their loved ones
[Music]
and earlier we spoke with the author of
that report who is currently at the
Turkish Syria border here's the latest
from DW correspondent Yoo Lian
well these latest developments of course
further complicate the battlefield I'm
here in the Turkish border town of
action color about five kilometers away
from the Syrian border which is towards
this direction now after the Kurdish led
forces there have officially turned to
the Syrian government and its ally
Russia for military assistant Bashar
al-assad and that's according to the
information we're getting there from
Syria is sending units of troops and
equipment we don't know how many troops
are how much equipment from Aleppo to
manwich in northern Syria now man [ __ ]
there is one of the targets one of the
areas the Turkish military is at trying
to attack is preparing to attack so
there is a very real risk these two
armies the Syrian army and the Turkish
army could be facing each other there
that could be clashes and this is of
course absolutely no good news